Jeannie how we reacted to kind of
certainly becoming I guess famous in
America we go to America now people know
who you are do you like it sometimes
sometimes they do sometimes people like
hi I love that that that would happen
here that sometimes I anytime I've gone
to you I've walked everywhere cuz I love
it and somebody will come up and kind of
high-five you and I love that you're
knocking but that doesn't happen here
but the other day I was with my grandson
who as you know looks very like egg
Sharon yes and a group of people with
only said may we have a photo and I said
yes of course could actually do that
weird connection with you and I'd sure
yes sure slept on my couch oh but six
weeks before he was famous how did that
up it sure if I was doing a radio show
in LA and it was it was it was a
satellite show and he knew that we do
music so he comes to my radio show and
hello James just trying to get my music
you know we love to hear music what I
was sure what let me hear it so he lets
me hear his music comes in my crib I had
now I got the bigger crib in the studio
is incredible
Kanye saw so so he plays on it you're
incredible so we start I said listen I
know you don't have anywhere to go just
chill here I was given a fool my
daughter was like who do you have over
here now so that would always have
people you know I would always like
champion the artist yeah and so I said
listen man I think you got the goods I
got to check you out though so I took
him down to this this show that I was
doing a live night every Monday in LA
downtown LA and it was like eight
hundred black people all black like just
the best musicians who plays you know
the guitar for sting and I mean the the
level of the music here and there was a
dude up there rapping and he was
sweating and he was black and another
girl she came up she sung and she was
black and it was thinking black man that
was incredible
so all of a sudden I say ladies and
gentlemen edge here he pops out red hair
and a ukulele one of my homies was an
incredible guitarist but he's just true
to the music came from us just black
black back any black right and he says
you're fast come on man what's this man
well says what you're doing to the room
right now maybe I respect the room and
it was just like a movie I said well
let's see what the kid has and when when
I found that ukulele got a standing
ovation in 12 minutes
Wow and the rest was history Wow
incredible yeah
[Applause]
[Music]